Joe Biden and to defund the police
Democrats have turned our once great
cities into cesspools a Bloodshed and
crime
Trump is already telling Endless Lies
the defund the police Democrats I still
never met them I get a few emails every
once in a while from people who go we
should defund the police
overwhelmingly what the left wants is
what I've outlined which is reform the
police retrain the police reorganize the
police
um and by the way the idea of rampant
crime
on average crime is down over time and a
lot of people don't want to acknowledge
this Oklahoma has a higher per capita
crime rate than New York State
Oklahoma City has a higher violent
violent crime rate per capita than New
York City
but it doesn't matter